[Musique]
le cirque de mafate
au coeur de ces montagnes se trouvent
les habitations les plus isolées de la
réunion accessible uniquement à pied ou
par hélicoptère
quelques 320 familles se sont installées
sur ces îles est escarpée la plupart des
habitations sont équipés de panneaux
photovoltaïques vieux de plus de vingt
ans en fin de vie et sans suivi
d'exploitation
la vétusté de ses installations favorise
le développement de la précarité
énergétique en 2017
le département de la réunion accompagne
dans sa politique d'aménagement des eaux
et pour l'égalité des territoires
un grand programme d'électrification sur
mafate des installations de production
d'énergie autonome 100% solaire sont
déployés sur les îles est l'objectif du
programme d'électrification c'est
d'évacuer les anciens générateur les
vieux panneau les vieilles batteries des
maîtres en filières de recyclage et de
réaliser des nouverau des nouveaux
ouvrages avec les dernières technologies
photovoltaïques des rats technologies de
stockage et de dimensionner en fait la
taille des installations le nombre de
panneaux aux besoins réels
aujourd'hui des familles voire même de
demander aux familles se projeter un
petit peu dans l'avenir pour avoir plus
de confort ici à roche plate 23 familles
seront équipés de nouveaux panneaux
photovoltaïques des études de
dimensionnement des équipements et des
besoins électriques sont menées auprès
des mafatais
j'entame équipements branchés parce que
l'installation est pas suffisante
du coup appris la division un
congélateur et là ce qui pourra lui par
la suite en fonction de ses besoins et
pourra mettre de côté à turin fédérateur
une machine à laver aussi est aussi sur
l'éclairage qui tire mon canapé l'estrie
site est vraiment deux modèles
d'installations photovoltaïques sont
retenus des centrales individuel pour
les habitations les plus isolées et des
micro réseau comme celui ci pour
desservir un ensemble d'habitations
proches afin de mutualiser les
installations nous a semblé plus
pertinent de réaliser une seule grosse
centrale mutualisés pour l'ensemble du
village avec un micro réseau de
distribution d'électricité enfouis sous
les sentiers pour aller alimenter
livraison chaque famille pour garantir
une complète autonomie énergétique des
îles est le remplacement des équipements
électriques domestiques énergivores par
des appareils plus performants est
indispensable le coût total de
remplacement de ces réfrigérateurs
congélateurs ou lave linge est estimé à
près de 300000 euros avec une subvention
de plus de 100000 euros pourvu par le
département 20 millions d'euros seront
investis pour que ma fat dispose d'une
énergie propre et durable
géré par le service public de
l'électricité ces réseaux
photovoltaïques sont des innovations
techniques et sociales en site isolé
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
[Musique]